[Music]
caring for our community's top dogs
today metro police let our crews go
behind the scenes with its k-9 unit so
we learned more about what these animals
do how they protect their human partners
and all the ways the department works to
keep them safe sasha loftus joins us in
studio tonight with a story that you'll
only see on eight
denise these dogs are simply amazing
they're extraordinarily powerful and
really ready for anything the k-9
officer we met today showed us the
difference he makes right here in las
vegas
with the wag of his tail and the flash
of a smile
this member of the police force is ready
for anything he's always ready to go do
his job meet officer arco one of metro's
finest like i get dressed he sees my
greens and
just he knows it's time for work his
handler sergeant eric hutchison gave us
a look inside the k-9 unit and showed us
what these animals can do they
drastically reduce officer-involved
shooting patrol dogs like arco go in
first to stop someone with a weapon and
prevent deadly force
government but these four-legged
fighters can get hurt too
several dogs have even been stabbed by
suspects
including k-9 officer hunter and k-9
officer kimura that's where
veterinarians like dr david mason come
in these officers are the first
point of call in some respects when an
animal gets injured he held a clinic
wednesday to teach officers how to step
in and help their dogs when the worst
happens anything that they can do to
stabilize fractures or if there's
punctures or lacerations can make a
difference it's just another way to
watch out for these partners who bring
so much they keep us safe but they also
keep the person safe that we're out
there confronting and do their best to
keep our entire community safe
and you can see officer arco in action
he will be competing in the las vegas
police k-9 trials in march the k-9 unit
also has a 20-22 calendar for sale all
proceeds go to the lvmpd foundation we
have a link to purchase it on our
website uh arko i believe is may of that
calendar there's a lot of belgian
malinois and a german shepherd they've
got this quiet intensity yeah he's a
dutch shepherd and they were saying that
they're great because they are really
easily trainable and he was he was
awesome i was saying i tried to play tug
of war with him and he almost knocked me
over
they're very strong the power and
strength